[Music]
every day Anna and her family like
millions of people in the European Union
countries eat a variety of food
this food can be produced locally or
come from countries throughout the world
in the rush of our daily lives most of
us are too busy to think about food
safety but we assume that the food we
buy and eat is of good quality and safe
to eat yet few of us ever really pauses
to think is our food safe to eat Anna
thinks about food safety all the time
Anna works as an auditor for the
European Commission within the
department responsible for health and
food safety the European Commission
employs an experienced team of
veterinarians medical doctors plant
health specialists and agronomist
together Anna and her colleagues are
responsible for checking in the European
Union and in countries exporting to the
European Union the the safety systems
put in place by national authorities to
control food safety animal health and
welfare as well as plant health are all
in line with the European Union's very
high standards in other words the
European Commission checks food safety
systems in the EU and in all the
countries across the world that export
to the EU ensuring that all of the food
we eat
no matter where it comes from is safe
however it is important to know that the
European Commission staff are active
they do not simply sit behind their
desks they are also responsible for
carrying out on the spot audits mainly
in EU countries but also worldwide in
countries exporting to the EU the
European Commission regularly sends
auditors like Anna and her colleagues
literally out into the field visiting
farms companies producing food and
companies selling food to consumers to
check that your country has put food
safety systems in place and carries out
the necessary controls
and that these operate effectively and
comply with EU rules if a country in the
EU or abroad fails to meet the high
standards required the country will have
to take corrective action otherwise the
food it produces may not be sold in the
EU and a non EU country may not be
allowed to export to the EU in the
future all in all the European
Commission works in close cooperation
with the national authorities of the EU
Member States and with countries
exporting to the EU to ensure the
highest standards of food safety and
quality are upheld and constantly
improved so that all EU consumers like
Anna and her family and you can have
confidence in the food we eat
you